es ist schön die voran ist hier noch
blau oder grün pink oder weiß was für
eine farbe die ich weiß es nicht ich
werde ganz ist es warum er nicht
herzlich willkommen beim neuen video ich
habe mal wieder herab dabei vielleicht
kennt ihn ja er war schon öfter mal
dabei und ja wir uns gedacht ich war das
letzte mal war ich das letzte mal bei
den friseuren ein glaube ich war da hast
du schießt werden ja jetzt da sieht man
eigentlich immer noch so kalt und ich
habe mir gedacht ich muss einfach mal
wieder zum friseur weil meine haare sind
viel zu lang
so macht man nicht so ähnlich wie keine
luft und darf ich mir gedacht es einfach
zu salopp und ja dass ich mir jetzt neu
werben bzw erstmal bisschen kürzer
schneiden und hier oben dann natürlich
noch lohnt wieder ne jetzt alles klar
aber diesmal bitte nicht so viel weißt
du hast jetzt mal ein paar tropfen macht
und alles war blond nur so stehen haften
aber kein bisschen heller sein dann der
mangel fest
was machst du eigentlich
setzt sich durch schwieriges und
fotografiere sollen
die richtung müsse
ich mache das schon was so einiges
wie kalt sei also im kühlschrank geholt
ja mal reichen kann wird jetzt werden
wir wollen farbe fertig wie lange dauert
das zehn minuten leute da alex ist
gerade auf die toilette gegangen in der
zeit ihr bereits kurz alles vorab ihr
dieses spray das versteck jetzt bei mir
mich die farbe zusammen als später
sprich dass auch sein kopf weniger deine
haare sind weiß geworden
er gehe aber macht vernünftig ne also
macht nur so ein bisschen strähnen artig
richtig professionell leute hier also
eine bürste machen jetzt beim fußball
nicht so nein weder insel komplett
anders gemacht ich möchte das jetzt
einfach nur so
die arbeit das war jetzt nicht so extrem
professionell das wissen wir auch ich
nicht kenne das so glaubt dass das immer
so ist herrlich trainer kriegt man das
einmal um und so dass sie gut auch so
dass so leute wir haben jetzt schon ein
gefärbtes masche ist nur so ein
spezielles harz bald drauf so lag damit
die farbe so ein bisschen in den armen
drinbleiben dass ich beim auch maschen
nicht direkt verlinkt solcher jetzt was
das letzte mal nicht gemacht jetzt noch
waren so gold das vergessen deswegen
waren gerade gold
rein machen war kein scheiß mit alex du
deine haare werden weiß dass gerade weiß
warum du hier genau das ist das kein
hallo ich kann da etwas anderes als wenn
jetzt das genauso lange wie das dann
doch nicht in die schule gehen wieder
wieder nicht mehr dabei nicht fehlen
aber da ich weiß nicht was dann
passierte jetzt noch und herren das ist
schon erfordern ist hier noch blau oder
grün pink oder was hast du denn für eine
farbe die ich weiß es nicht ich werde
ganz ist es war nichts zu sehen
und jetzt und es widerstand kann
erklären
derweil werden die usa spielte versteht
und ich weiß wie du machst immer bremsen
weiß was denn wo ist da mit den bremsen
zum friseur als mal lächeln denn wer hat
heute auch ostermontag ich kann noch so
nicht wieder irgendwo hingehen jetzt
irgendwas alter ohne scheiß was das
alter
ja weiß wert sein wir sind nicht auf
seine channel hier wäre das wollen sie
bis jetzt habe ich wirklich hab hab ich
wenigstens was den titel schreiben kann
damit die klicks viele oder was ja den
bereich das war es erstmal würde ich
sagen wir gehen jetzt nicht zum friseur
schaut er noch bei ihnen vorbei wir
machen jetzt ein video also mit meinen
neuen haben könnte es länger die perfekt
geworden sind ja also es geht jetzt raus
das weiße wieder ski profis wir drehen
jetzt ein video aus einem kellerschacht
das ganze um in der video beschreibung
von links check das ab und die müssen
uns beeilen weil ich musste zum vize